NEW DEVELOPMENT ON THAT STORY,
WE WILL BRING IT TO YOU IN JUST
A MOMENT BUT FIRST TONIGHT, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
YOU CAN BE FORGIVEN IF THE
AMOUNTS OF A EVENTS IN THE MONTH
CAUGHT YOU BY SURPRISE, YOU’VE
BEEN USED TO DISMISSING THE
AMERICAN LEFT OUT OF HAND AS A
JOKE BECAUSE THEY ARE.
SINCE THE DAY DONALD TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BEEN
HELPLESSLY DISORGANIZED AND
TOTALLY INEFFECTIVE AS A
POLITICAL PARTY, THEY WASTED
YEARS CHASING INVISIBLE RUSSIAN
AGENTS AND MAKING WEIRD AND
UNINTELLIGIBLE SOUNDS ABOUT
SOMETHING CALLED UKRAINE.
STILL NOT SURE WHAT THEY MEANT
BY THAT.
THEIR ENTIRE POLITICAL STRATEGY
WAS BIZARRE AND IN THE END IT
WAS COUNTER PRODUCTIVE AND IT
HURT THEM WITH VOTERS, THEY WENT
DOWN IN THE POLLS.
ONLY BUFFOONS DO THAT IN
POLITICS.
THESE PEOPLE COULDN’T ORGANIZE
YOUR KIDS BIRTHDAY PARTY, THEY
DIDN’T MAKE THEIR BEDS THIS
MORNING.
AND YET SUDDENLY OUT OF NOWHERE,
THEY ROARED BACK AND TOOK OVER
THE COUNTRY.
THEY DID IT IN LESS TIME THAN IT
TAKES MOST PEOPLE TO GO ON
SPRING VACATION.
WHAT HAPPENED?
HOW DID THEY DO THAT?
WELL, IT’S SIMPLE.
NOBODY STOPS THEM.
THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION TO THEIR
POWER GRAB.
THE OTHER SIDE SURRENDERED ON
DAY ONE WITHOUT A FIGHT.
THE REST OF US WATCHED ALL OF
THIS WITH OUR JAWS HANGING OPEN
IN SHOCK, THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
WE EXPECTED, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO REGULARLY VOTE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY PRECISELY
BECAUSE THEY WOULD LIKE SOMEONE
TO PROTECT THIS COUNTRY FROM THE
CRAZED IDEOLOGUES WHO SEEK TO
DESTROY.
THERE ARE MANY OF THEM, YOU’RE
WATCHING THEM ON TELEVISION NOW.
THERE IS NOT REALLY ANOTHER
REASON TO VOTE REPUBLICAN UNLESS
YOU HAVE ARE ONE OF THOSE RARE P
WHO LIKES POINTLESS FOREIGN WARS
AND SUCKING UP TO BANKS.
YOU VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS TO
PROTECT YOU FROM THIS BUT WHEN
THE MOMENT OF CRISIS CAME,
REPUBLICANS RAN AWAY.
MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES WERE
LOOTED AND BURNED ON TELEVISION.
CITIZENS WERE BEATEN AND
MURDERED.
WORKS OF PUBLIC ART WERE
DESTROYED, AMERICAN HISTORY,
THOSE SHARED EXPERIENCES THAT
BIND US TOGETHER AS A NATION,
WAS PLUNDERED AND COMPLETELY
REWRITTEN BY ILLITERATE VANDALS.
AND EVERYWHERE AS THEY WATCHED,
AMERICANS WERE AFRAID NOT SIMPLY
FOR THEIR SAFETY BUT AFRAID FOR
THEIR JOBS, REPUTATIONS,
FAMILIES.
MANY AMERICANS WERE FIRED
ABRUPTLY IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SEVERE RECESSION, DOOMED TO
RUIN, FOR NOTHING.
BY SAYING THE WRONG THING,
LOOKING THE WRONG WAY, LIKING
THE WRONG TWEET.
THAT HAPPENED, IT’S HAPPENING
NOW.
SOME OF THE ACCUSED WERE SO
TERRIFIED, THEY DENOUNCE THEIR
OWN FAMILY.
WIFE, BROTHER, DAUGHTER.
IN THE END THEY WERE DESTROYED
ANYWAY BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT
HAPPENS, YOUR DESTROYED ANYWAY.
MOST AMERICANS ASSUMED THEY
WOULD NEVER LIVE TO SEE A MOMENT
LIKE THIS, BUT THEY HAVE, IT’S
STILL GOING ON.
ON THE QUESTION THAT HANGS IN
THE AIR IS WHERE ARE OUR
PROTECTORS?
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE RIOT, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION, THE NATION’S SINGLE
LARGEST CONSERVATIVE THINK TANK,
IT HAS CONSUMED BILLIONS OF
DONOR DOLLARS.
THE PRESIDENT OF HERITAGE ROAD
AND OP-ED ACCUSING AMERICA OF
BEING IRREDEEMABLY RACIST.
YOU PROBABLY SENT HER MONEY.
AS AMERICA BURNED, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE HERITAGE FOUNDATION
PYLON.
AND SHE WASN’T ALONE IN THAT, SO
MANY ON THE RIGHT DID EXACTLY
THE SAME THING.
MEANWHILE, THEY DID NOTHING,
THEY DIDN’T LIFT A FINGER TO
HELP THE PEOPLE THEY PROMISED
THEY HAD PLEDGED TO PROTECT FROM
OTHER VOTERS AND THEIR DONORS.
THEY SAY THEY DID EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
DEMANDS OF THE PEOPLE TORMENTING
THEM.
RATIONAL REPUBLICANS DECIDED TO
MAKE REINING IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEIR TOP LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY.
THEY BLAMED THE COPS.
THEY DIDN’T BLAME THE RIOTERS,
THEN REPUBLICANS BRAG ABOUT
THREE MORE CRIMINALS FROM JAIL,
THE LAST THING WE NEEDED.
IN THE STATE OF IOWA, THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
THAT SHE WAS GIVING FELONS, BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER, JUST DOING IT,
SIGNING IT.
ORDINARY AMERICANS CAME UNDER
ATTACK FOR THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN, ACTS OF ACTUAL RACISM
WHERE PEOPLE WERE BEING HURT FOR
THEIR RACE, SOMETHING THEY CAN’T
CONTROL, SOMETHING THEY WERE
BORN WITH AND YET NO REPUBLICANS
ROSE TO DEFEND THEM.
REPUBLICANS REFUSED TO DEFEND
THE PRINCIPLE OF EQUALITY UNDER
THE LAW, THE FOUNDATION OF THIS
COUNTRY, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE HAVE.
NOT DEFEND IT.
REALLY, IN THE END, THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO GAVE ANYTHING IN THE
REVOLUTION WERE THE ONES WAGING
IT.
OUR LEADERS, VERY MUCH INCLUDING
A REPUBLICAN LEADERS,
SHAMEFULLY, WERE FOCUSED ON
MEETING THEIR DEMANDS.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE CONCLUDE FROM
WHAT WE JUST SAW?
THE MESSAGE UNFORTUNATELY COULD
NOT BE CLEARER.
VOTING IS FOR FOOLS.
YOU VOTE COME UP WITH THESE
PEOPLE INTO OFFICE WITH THEIR
VOTES, AND IN RETURN THEY
PATRONIZE YOU AND WHEN IT
MATTERS, THEY ABANDON YOU.
THEY HAVE CONTEMPT FOR YOU, YOU
CAN SMELL IT, IT’S OBVIOUS.
VOTING DOESN’T WORK.
WHEN YOU RIOT AND YOU BURN
THINGS AND YOU HURT PEOPLE, YOU
GET A VERY DIFFERENT RESPONSE.
LEADERS SNAPPED TO ATTENTION,
THEY TIPTOE AROUND YOUR
FEELINGS, THEY GIVE YOU WHAT YOU
WANT AS HER REPUBLICANS ARE,
WRITING WORKS.
THAT’S THE MESSAGE THEY’RE
SENDING, THINK ABOUT THAT, THAT
THE MOST DANGEROUS POSSIBLE
MESSAGE YOU CAN SEND BECAUSE IT
GUARANTEES MY VIOLENCE.
YOU’VE GOT TO WONDER HOW ALL OF
THIS WOULD’VE PLAYED OUT IF
BARACK OBAMA WAS STILL
PRESIDENT.
LET’S SAY IT WAS THE SUMMER OF
2011, RIGHT BEFORE OBAMA’S
REELECTION CAMPAIGN STARTED IN
EARNEST, IMAGINE THAT THAT
POLITICALLY CRITICAL MOMENT,
VIOLENT MOBS OF MITT ROMNEY
SUPPORTERS BEGAN BURNING AND
LOOTING AMERICAN CITIES.
IMAGINE IF THE MOB DEFACED AND T
DOWN STATUES OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING IN PUBLIC
PARKS, IF EVERY STREET SIGN IN
AMERICA I DENTING ON
MARTIN LUTHER KING BOULEVARD WAS
RIPPED TO THE GROUND AND DEFACED
WITH GRAFFITI, MOST AMERICANS
WOULD FIND THAT APPALLING AND
DISGUSTING, WE CERTAINLY WOULD
PAY LET’S SAY THE MOB KEPT DOING
IT BECAUSE NOBODY STOPS THEM.
IMAGINE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
PLANNED TO VOTE FOR BARACK OBAMA
IN THE FALL KNEW THEY COULDN’T
ADMIT THAT IN PUBLIC, CITIZENS
WEARING OBAMA HATS WERE
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED, PUNCHED IN
THE FACE, THROWN TO THE SIDEWALK
AND KICKED, IMAGINE IF ANYONE
WHO SPOKE OUT AGAINST THE MOBS
OR SHOWED SUPPORT FOR OBAMA’S
CAMPAIGN WAS CENSORED OR DEPLAT
FORMED BY TECH MONOPOLIES THAT
OPERATED AT THE PLEASURE OF
FEDERAL REGULATORS.
IMAGINE IF THOSE SAME MONOPOLIES
CENSORED PRESIDENT OBAMA
HIMSELF.
SO ASK YOURSELF SINCERELY IF ALL
THAT HAPPENED, HOW DO YOU THINK
BARACK OBAMA WOULD’VE RESPONDED?
BY TWEETING ANGRY THINGS?
BY EFFECTIVELY APOLOGIZING TO
THE MOB, MEETING THEIR DEMANDS
FOR "REFORM" AND DECLARING A NEW
NATIONAL HOLIDAY AT THEIR
REQUEST?
PROBABLY NOT.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE
BARACK OBAMA DOING THAT, IT’S
HARD TO IMAGINE HIM COMPLAINING
THAT AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HE DIDN’T HAVE THE
POWER TO STOP POLITICAL VIOLENCE
OR PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF AN
ELECTION OR PROTECT FREE SPEECH
OR PUBLIC ART OR THE NATION’S
HISTORY ITSELF.
NO, THAT WOULD NOT HAPPEN.
INSTEAD, WITHIN ABOUT 10 MINUTES
HE WOULD SEE THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INDICT EVERYTHING A
PERSON INVOLVED ON FEDERAL
CONSPIRACY AND CIVIL RIGHTS
CHARGES.
YOU WOULD WATCH AS SEAL TEAM SIX
RECLAIMED DOWNTOWN SEATTLE,
AIRBORNE UNITS WOULD DROPPED
THROUGH THE SKY, YOU WOULD SEE
WHATEVER IT TOOK TO STOP THE
CHAOS.
THAT REVOLUTION WOULD NOT LAST
LONG.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT
BARACK OBAMA, AND WE DO, BUT HE
NEVER DOUBTED HE HAD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO ACT
AND HE DID ACT.
OBAMA KNEW A THREAT WHEN HE SAW
ONE.
OUR REPUBLICAN LEADERS DON’T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY,
THEY DON’T BELIEVE THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE, THEY DON’T SEE THE
THREAT, THEY DON’T WANT TO SEE
THE THREAT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY CAN’T FACE THE MOB, THEY
KNOW THEY ARE TOO WEAK SO THEY
OFFER TRINKETS AND HOPE THE MOB
WILL GO AWAY BUT IT WON’T, MOBS
CAN’T BE STATED.
WE THOUGHT REPUBLICANS
UNDERSTOOD THAT, THAT’S WHY WE
SUPPORTED THEM BUT CRISIS HAS
REVEALED THE TRUTH.